hi everyone what a thrill to be here I
want everyone to take a moment look
around the room why on earth would we
want to be anywhere else but here and I
want to thank the Academy first of all
for the plant-based meal I I didn't know
it's gonna be an actual plan at least it
looked appetizing though like day of the
Triffids
where are my film nerds that was for my
I was for my film nerves alrighty
I've said I feel so grateful to be part
of this community there are so many of
you in this room who I really admire and
whose films have inspired me many of you
have worked with known or maybe just mat
like Charlize Theron I don't know if you
recall but you can apply Charlie Cera
but uh we actually had dinner once back
in 1997 at Matsuhisa on La Cienega as
you and me and Craig Bierko and yeah we
talked about life and you're the crunchy
crab well I don't know I know if you
remember anyway congratulations but a
long time since I saw is so dude doing a
hell of a job out there and you win the
prize for best date bringing your mom
that's the best that's the best today we
are here to recognize your profound
imprint on the industry and to
acknowledge all of your contributions
big and small to the history of motion
pictures and the fact that you're in
this room is testament that you were at
the pinnacle of your profession and you
have done an incredible job now my job
is to get you all up on that riser
without anyone tearing a meniscus so
here we go and now I'm going to be
saying all the names this is exciting
I'm excited once I say your name
you can go tour you can head the stage
managers will help you up on the riser
so first name kirsten anderson-lopez
original song into the unknown
frozen to
[Applause]
Robert Lopez original song into the
unknown
frozen to
[Applause]
David white makeup and hair styling
Maleficent mistress of evil
[Applause]
Tom Eagles film editing
Jojo rabbit
[Applause]
Scott silver adapted screenplay Joker
Chris Butler best animated feature film
missing Lee
[Applause]
Neal Scanlan visual effects Star Wars
rise of Skywalker
[Applause]
Kirsty Wilson Cairns original screenplay
1917
[Applause]
Randy Newman original score' marriage
story and original song I can't let you
throw yourself away from Toy Story for
[Applause]
Christian P Minkler sound mixing once
upon a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
Katherine Hendrickson best animated
short film KITT bull Russell Earl visual
effects avengers endgame
Paul Massey sound mixing Ford versus
Ferrari
Josh Cooley best animated feature film
Toy Story for
[Applause]
Gary Young sock cam Best Documentary
Short subject in the absence Stepan
Robley visual effects the Irishman
[Applause]
[Music]
Colet sanstead Best Documentary Short
subject walk run ChaCha
[Applause]
Yves Pia Best live action short film
nefta Football Club
[Applause]
Todd Maitland sound mixing Joker
[Applause]
[Music]
dharia koshcheeva best animated short
film Dussehra
[Applause]
Christopher Peterson costume design the
Irishman ryan johnson original
screenplay knives out
[Applause]
[Music]
Nancy egg production design once upon a
time in Hollywood
[Applause]
arjan sutnar best animated feature film
missing link
[Applause]
autonomous Georg EF Best Documentary
Feature honey lads
[Applause]
John Baptist Best Documentary Short
subject life overtakes me Christine
Samuelsson Best Documentary Short
subject life overtakes me Roger Guyot
visual effects Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker James Mangold Best Picture
Ford versus Ferrari Bryan Buckley Best
live action short film
Sariah
[Applause]
our en Philips costume design once upon
a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
the paw Paris Best Picture 1917
lubos Stefan off best documentary
feature and director of north
Macedonia's nominee for Best
International feature film honey land
Michael mckusker film editing Ford vs.
Ferrari
[Applause]
Matt LaFave Best live action short film
Sariah
[Applause]
Allen Robert Murray sound editing Joker
[Applause]
Patrick to back visual effects Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker
[Applause]
while e-statement sound editing once
upon a time in Hollywood
[Music]
Thelma Schoonmaker film editing the
Irishman
[Music]
Regina graves production designed the
Irishman
[Applause]
Todd Phillips Best Picture directing and
adapted screenplay
Joker Mach DuPont Elise best animated
feature film I lost my body
[Music]
Rodrigo Prieto cinematography the
Irishman
Laura Knicks Best Documentary Short
subject walk run ChaCha
[Applause]
Pierce Tina bar fraud Best Documentary
Feature the cave
Bernie Taupin original song I'm gonna
love me again from Rocket Man
[Applause]
Chelsea wins Stanley Best Picture Joe
Joe Rabbit
[Applause]
Guillaume Roshan visual-effects 1917
David Heyman best picture marriage story
and once upon a time in Hollywood
[Music]
Matthieu a cherry best animated short
film hair love
[Music]
Tiago Pavan Best Documentary Feature the
edge of democracy
[Music]
Miriam Joubert Best live action short
film Brotherhood Rachel Tate sound
editing 1917
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oliver tarney sound editing 1917
Vivian Baker makeup and hairstyling
bombshell Leandra Esteva Karina visual
effects the Irishman
Thomas Newman original score' 1917
mark
Elano sound mixing ad astra
and once upon a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
laura dern actress in a supporting role
marriage star
gingka gota best animated feature film
Klaus Jeff growth film editing Joker
[Applause]
[Music]
Robert De Niro Best Picture the Irishman
Kathy Bates actress in a supporting role
Richard Jewell
Kazuhiro makeup and hairstyling
bombshell
[Applause]
psycho white tea tea best picture
adapted screenplay Georgia rabbit
Roger Deakins Cinematography 1917
[Applause]
[Music]
Andrew Buckland film editing Ford vs.
Ferrari
Eliot Newman visual-effects
Lion King Michael Minkler sound mixing
once upon a time in Hollywood
Suchi song best animated short film
sister
[Applause]
Joshua Brian Campbell original song
stand up from Harriet and Morgan makeup
and hairstyling bombshell
[Music]
Dennis Gassner production design 1917
Matthew would sound editing Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker
[Applause]
Barbara Ling production design once upon
a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
Florence view actress in a supporting
role Little Women
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jonathan pryce actor in a leading role
the two popes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Kalem McDougall best picture 1970
Steven Zaillian adopted screenplay the
Irishman
song Joong ho best picture correctly
[Applause]
Best Picture directing original
screenplay and director of South Korea's
nominee for Best International feature
film parasite my old friend Charlize
Theron actress in a leading role
bombshell
[Music]
Quentin Tarantino this picture directing
original screenplay once upon a time in
Hollywood
[Music]
[Applause]
David gia Marco sound mixing Ford versus
Ferrari Gregg Butler visual effects 1917
[Applause]
Cynthia
areevo actress in a leading role and
original song stand up from Harriet
[Applause]
Damien Mel Gabi live action short film
nefta football club
[Music]
[Applause]
Johanna not a Sagara Best Documentary
Feature the edge of democracy Amy Pascal
best picture Little Women
[Applause]
Laurens sure cinematography Joker
Jeremy clapping best animated feature
film I lost my body
[Applause]
[Music]
Jeff Reichert Best Documentary Feature
American Factory
[Applause]
[Music]
Leonardo DiCaprio actor in a leading
role once upon a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
Hilda who's now go tear Original Score
Joker
Sam Mendes Best Picture directing an
original screenplay 1917 tom Hosanna CH
sound mixing Joker
rev incent production design Jojo rabbit
[Music]
Travis night best animated feature film
missing link
[Applause]
Paul Gooch makeup and hairstyling
Maleficent mistress of evil
[Applause]
Elena Andre Achieva Best Documentary
Short subject learning to skateboard in
a war zone if you're a girl
[Applause]
[Music]
Bonnie Arnold best animated feature film
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world
[Applause]
[Music]
Emma Tillinger koskoff best picture the
Irishman and the Joker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
arjan tighten makeup and hairstyling
Maleficent mistress of evil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sammy Khan Best Documentary Short
subject st. Louis Superman
[Applause]
Tom Johnson sound mixing ad astra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Melissa Roman best animated feature film
Klaus
[Applause]
Petra Costa Best Documentary Feature the
edge of democracy
[Applause]
jeno topping best picture Ford versus
Ferrari
[Applause]
Stuart Wilson sound mixing 1917
Robert legato visual effects The Lion
King
[Applause]
[Music]
brad pitt actor in a supporting role
once upon a time in Hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
Stephen Boatner Best Documentary Feature
American Factory
[Applause]
[Music]
Julie Reichert Best Documentary Feature
American Factory
[Music]
David a cord sound editing Star Wars
rise of Skywalker
[Applause]
Jonas Rivera best animated feature film
Toy Story 4
[Music]
[Applause]
tamarah coat f Scott best documentary
feature and director of north
Macedonia's nominee for Best
International feature film honey land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Han Jin Hwan Original Screenplay
parasite
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Greta Gerwig adapted screenplay little
women
[Applause]
Noah Baumbach Best Picture Original
Screenplay marriage story
[Applause]
[Music]
the zupanic sound mixing joker
[Applause]
my ass say Roubaix Oh costume design
Jojo rabbit
[Applause]
Al Pacino actor in a supporting role the
Irishman
[Applause]
[Music]
Lodge Lee director of Frances nominee
for Best International feature film they
missile
[Applause]
[Music]
Karen Rupert Toliver best animated short
film hair love
[Applause]
[Music]
Diane Warren original song I'm standing
with you from breakthrough mark bridges
costume design Joker
Renee Zellweger actress in a leading
role Judy
dean deblois best animated feature film
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Maria Gracia to Jean Best live action
short film Brotherhood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for us beyond Best Documentary Feature
the king
[Applause]
[Music]
Pablo helman visual effects the irishman
[Music]
yang Jin mo film editing parasite
jaren Blaschke cinematography the
lighthouse
[Applause]
heep-ha tuned production design parasite
[Applause]
[Music]
Edward Watts best documentary feature
for sama
[Applause]
[Music]
lise and dales production design 1917
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Keenen penguin best picture 1917
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew R Jones visual effects The Lion
King
[Applause]
Shannon Macintosh best picture once upon
a time in Hollywood
[Music]
Roseanna
sullivan best animated short film kit
bull
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Marshall curry Best live action short
film the neighbors window Shane Boris
Best Documentary Feature the edge of
democracy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Carthew Neal best picture Jojo rabbit
Sandy Powell costume designed the
irishman
[Applause]
Naomi Don makeup and hairstyling 1917
[Applause]
[Music]
Dominic 2e visual effects 1917 and Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker
[Applause]
[Music]
Anthony McCartin adapted screenplay the
two popes
[Applause]
Carroll died singer Best Documentary
Short subject learning to skateboard in
a war zone if you're a girl
[Music]
[Applause]
Donald Sylvester sound editing Ford
versus frying
[Applause]
not Aitken visual-effects
avengers endgame
Bradford Lewis best animated feature
film How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world
Sigrid Nike Air Best Documentary Feature
the cave
[Applause]
Nelson suppo Goethe Couser
visual-effects the Irishman
[Music]
mark Nielsen best animated feature film
Toy Story for Jane Rosenthal Best
Picture the Irishman
[Applause]
he sang tune Best Documentary Short
subject in the absence
Kwak chin a best picture the parasite
waagh all huh teeth Best Documentary
Feature for sama
[Applause]
Delphine's you are Best live action
short film a sister
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Stephen a morrow sound mixing Ford
versus Ferrari snip tree mudra Best
Documentary Short subject st. Louis
Superman
Bob Shaw productions design the Irishman
sérgio Pablos best animated feature film
Klaus
[Applause]
I present to you the ninety second
Academy Award nominees class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right okay we're about to take the
historic photo most important thing
please remove your badges make your
badges give you a moment take your
badges off
all right so tough when everyone has
their badge off all righty
okay now direct your attention to the
red see that up in the sky the red
flashing light in the ceiling that's
where the camera is we're going to take
the photo six times got six chances to
get it right I'm gonna cap I'm gonna
count you down from three is everyone
ready ones ready for the picture okay
three two one smile here we go again try
to look like you're having a good time
three two one three two one try to make
a face that looks comfortable even
though you're not we're gonna go again
three two one all right last chance to
get it right big smile come on you're
actors you know how to do this three two
one you're a winner
[Applause]
you